in a Counter-Strike match information
can mean the difference between success
or failure as a result smoke grenades
have become a Cornerstone of Team
tactics
Counter-Strike 2's new game engine we've
evolved smokes and made them Dynamic
smoke grenades now create volumetric 3D
objects that live in the world
now not only do all players see the same
smoke regardless of position but the
smoke can interact with the environment
in interesting ways it reacts to
lighting
grows to fill spaces naturally the shape
of the smoke cloud can be pushed and
carved by bullets and grenades
in Counter-Strike 2 smoke grenades
provide even more tactical opportunities
they're just going to look and play
better
[Music]
[Applause]